washington state right now has just
banned the term marijuana
they haven't banned marijuana they would
never ban the peruvian parsley up in
washington state but they have banned
the term
marijuana and they've banned the term
marijuana because apparently the word
marijuana is racist
the term marijuana itself is pejorative
and racist even though it seems simple
because it's just one word but the
reality is we are
healing the wrongs that were committed
against black and brown
people around cannabis it was negatively
associated with mexican immigrants it
was used as a racist terminology to um
lock up black and brown people
it's because of the racism of the word
marijuana
that people who used illicit drugs were
thrown in prison
that's what no it's because they were
committing crimes that's why it's
because that was illegal and then people
used it they actually didn't even really
and in recent decades no one goes to
prison for simple possession they all go
to prison for dealing and for
trafficking and they usually plead it
down so even to say they went to jail
for using an illegal drug that's just
not true
they went to prison for peddling poison
to young people
and working for criminal cartels no
matter where they are in the food chain
and we say no the only it's not their
fault that they committed crimes it's
because of the racism of the word
marijuana okay what are we going to call
it haitian oregano peruvian parsley what
do you
do okay now in the law we're just going
to call it dubies
we're just is that is that going to
change anything no the question is
should this substance be legal
or not should we prosecute it or not
right now go to helixsleep.com
knowles i'm trying to invite you into my
bed
okay please enter my boudoir to see how
great my helix mattress is well not my
mattress actually that's kind of the
whole point you shouldn't be sleeping on
a mattress that is made for someone else
you are unique you should get a mattress
made for you helix sleep has a quiz it
takes just two minutes to complete it
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else that would be crazy with
helix you're getting that mattress that
you know is going to be perfect for the
way you sleep they got soft medium firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot mattress is
great for spinal alignment to prevent
morning aches and pains even a helix
plus mattress for plus sized sleepers if
you are looking for a mattress you take
the quiz you order the mattress that
you're matched to and the mattress comes
right to your door shipped for free you
don't ever need to go to that mattress
store again head on over and get up to
200 off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at helix
sleep.com
knowles one of my least popular views is
i don't see any reason to legalize
marijuana
i don't see any reason because one of my
strongest arguments for keeping it
illegal is that the potheads who really
really are insanely pro-legalization are
almost always extremely airheaded libs
i'm not saying that some people on the
right don't like a little peruvian
parsley too but the ones who make it
their whole identity the people who just
clamor for it they're protesting to
legalize they're always huge libs and i
see no reason to give them what they
want in that especially in that case why
do we why do we need to
why do we need to introduce a new
drug to the mainstream i i don't see any
reason to do it but regardless of what
you feel about it maybe you you're the
most pro legalized pot person in the
world surely you don't think
that the political issue will be
resolved by just banning the word
because it's racist why is it racist
well because it's a spanish word why is
it a spanish word because it comes from
latin america that's why
it's not it's not like marijuana was
discovered in uh
i don't know boston right it's not it's
not as though this it was discovered in
liverpool no it comes that's the area
that it comes from
and it's not but the word racist gets
you off the hook for anything the word
race if you just invoke racism no matter
how tenuous the argument is that will
get you off the hook for anything that
is the magical word it's how the libs
have been able to destroy our drug laws
our criminal justice system our
immigration system uh it's been how
they've been able to are are equal
protection it's it's how they've been
able to destroy even fairness and hiring
and college admissions they say that if
you don't support racial quotas for
certain groups and if you don't support
uh uh giving a boost to certain people
on the color of the race then you're a
racist so they just use the word racist
and they band it about and they get
whatever they want because they've
counted conservatives into submission
i'm glad you like that clip now
ding ding ding ring that bell subscribe
get all the notifications for the
michael knowles show you can also head
on over to apple podcast spotify stitch
or google play wherever you get your
audio podcast subscribe to the michael
knowles show we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you